here is majorcus once again this guy
never stops with this guy talking about
violence in America and you're not going
to believe who he's the most scared of
the President yesterday uh at his
commencement address for the Howard
University graduates called white
supremacy the the major domestic Terror
threat in this country is that correct
uh it tragically is you know um in the
terrorism context domestic violent
extremism is uh our greatest threat uh
right now individuals are driven to
violence because of ideologies of hate
anti-government sentiments false
narratives personal Grievances and alike
and regrettably we have seen a rise in
white supremacy first off I want to be
very clear about one thing I have a lot
of anti-government sentiment I'm not a
terrorist and I am not calling to
overthrow the government but these
buffoons you should be resentful uh and
sort of angry at these people you can't
take the law into your own hands but it
is that guy's job to make sure we have a
border and he's actually making sure we
don't have a border he should I don't
know if it's impeached what do you do
with these people you like I don't even
know what the technical term is but the
guy should be given the boot I think
that would be the technical term
foreign
[Music]